our team put together this touching
illustrated short let's check it out
my dearest Natalie as I write this
letter it's the middle of the night in
late summer an hour ago you cracked the
equations necessary to power the force
field we showed me up tonight my
magnificent daughter and I couldn't be
happier or prouder of that I always knew
you were special but never did I film
that the little girl who taught her
stuffed in AC multiplication tables grow
up to master quantum laser mechanics I
ever showed the syndicate that the
modified containment forcefield will be
operational in a month's time and it's
all thanks to you
I may be just a doddering old fool
trying to hold on to mommy bay a little
while longer before he loses her to
adopt it but I do see you I see this
strong brilliant wonderful young woman
you've become
and I know when the day comes that I'm
no longer with you we are going to be
just fine
the games will be brilliant because you
are brilliant my daughter can and will
do anything she wants in this life
because she is the smartest woman in the
frontier she tend to mocha pour toujours
papa
[Music]
I did it Baba I hope whatever you are
you're cheering for me ladies and
gentlemen
Austin joining the arena and joining me
now we have three gentlemen who brought
her to life Griffin will and Tom thank
you so much for joining us here Wow it's
about that I mean Bob will come from the
chat man because that was just that was
just that was the feels right there hit
me rice frightened but Griffin will
start with you but you're one of the
legend designers and I'm curious on the
approach that you guys took toward
making Watson a character that has
impact in the arena so Watson really
started as a conversation between a
friend of mine and I who he's an
engineer and he has this really
methodical interesting way of taking
really complex problems and
systematically solving them and so I
kind of thought what would it be like if
we took the sort of the defensive
complexity of Apex and introduced a
character that could really create a an
ecosystem engagement you can survive the
really aggressive third-party meta all
that stuff so the the idea behind Watson
really is that if you if you plan and
you sort of adapt to the environment you
really know the map and you work closely
with your team that you can really
create these strong defenses that that
people are gonna really have to think
about in terms of how yeah they push on
you and that sort of thing so that the
current meta of I hear gunfire and I hit
it as hard as I can you know with
Bangalore Wraith octane all of those
we're trying to sort of bump that meta a
little bit and make it so that this this
more stance RTS kind of play style has
breathing breathing yeah try to provide
like options for the players yes yeah I
want to be able to play that hyper
aggressive approach whether you're
running like a composition that contains
like a typical one which would be like a
Pathfinder Wraith and a lifeline for
that support yeah you can you can play
in the composition
like this they kind of counter yeah one
another so that that'sthat's gonna be
really fun we're gonna dive into the
abilities and everything that she does
because let me tell you it's insane now
as far as the look and feel my favorite
part about excellent apex Legends is
that the characters the legends
themselves they stand out when you're
looking from far away you see the
silhouette and you know exactly who it
is that you're about to engage with what
were some of the complexities in
bringing a character like Watson to life
yeah so it's a collaborative effort you
know got out Heath and Sam animation
Department everybody kind of works
together we were given a specific set of
skills that she would be using abilities
from Gryphon and that's kind of what we
had to go off of so we had to he did a
great job of like bringing it all
together giving her a sort of a grounded
aesthetic using she had to look like she
was using electricity and stuff like
that so look rubber gloves and the coils
and the wires and pushing her silhouette
at the same time making her stand you
have to be able to read who she is from
different distances from there from
there you can really go in and sculpt
all the details out and work with the
animators to really bring her life give
her personality and everything that she
does with her abilities and that - yeah
and there's some really cool stuff there
as well every every part that Watson she
takes out an item in her kit it's
actually like on her person oh yeah you
see it happen yeah and those are all
very meticulously designed by the
concept artist and then and then modeled
out in 3d so yeah it's all functional
that's great in the in the world yeah so
now you get to the to the gameplay the
look but the story you know cuz you got
to hit us in the fields right like super
hard and you just did that
Watson's backstory who she is
let's let's dive deeper yeah that was
kind of different from the way we
usually do things because usually it's
very collaborative and we're creating
the character at the same time all the
different departments and we're working
together
Watson was different she was already
designed and and drawn when I got her
and one of the great things about
working at respondus is they they
encouraged us to create characters that
are non-traditional and there are
characters you haven't seen in video
games before and to kind of branch out
and see what else you know what other
people have the people can we represent
out there and so Watson is a very
different character than I've ever seen
in a video game at least and everything
is based off of what these guys created
I mean it's all every single part of her
backstory is connected somehow to either
her abilities or her look and now it was
something that kind of stuck out to me
so am I correct in assuming that Watson
played a big role in the arena itself
yes so Watson and her father actually
invented the ring okay
and so she grew up in the arena
literally in the arena when they were
building it and we're gonna start to
you're gonna see with Watson and moving
forward we're gonna start to build the
lore of this world a little bit are you
gonna find out who created the games
they mentioned the syndicate in there so
we'll talk about the syndicate down the
road your build more and more of a
universe yeah which is great so she's in
here so all the legends must know her oh
yeah she was their kid sister basically
she was always hanging around the arena
and if she got to know all the legends
and got to watch all of them she's not a
mercenary she's not a soldier
you know she her roles of support and so
she everybody loves Watson she's the one
person that could probably unite all the
legends together cluding caustic caustic
respect sir she's a scientist okay she's
an engineer okay strong word for cops
yeah I don't know if caustic likes
anybody okay that's that's fair well
yeah that's cool I mean blown away by
this character so far now I mentioned
before we're gonna talk about the
abilities because when you revealed
these to me I was floored
jaw-dropping in a lot of people online
were kind of like guessing mm-hmm as to
like what it would be and I'm very happy
to see that a lot of them some some had
the right idea but for the most part
what she's capable of doing is
ridiculous so let's talk about the act
of first thing defenses yes so the the
Watson has more interrelated abilities
than probably any other current
we have you really need to understand
how they all interact the fences you can
place 12 nodes and you can use these in
any permutation you want part of why we
sort of went was that her being such a
brilliant electrical engineer is because
we really want to reinforce both
mechanically and thematically how
creative the player can be with these
basically we're just giving you free
rein to place these however you want and
figure out and the players they like I
just saw right now don't know if that
was intentional so the when your
teammates go through it's yeah it's off
so I'm down and they run through the
gate there's a gate deactivate yes oh so
there's a lot of different interactions
a lot of different ways that you can
interact with the gates with other
characters the ultimate is we call it an
interception pylon it shoots down
bombardments incoming grenades stops arc
star spam and it charges your team
shield
and also if the Watsons cooldown is
slower when she's away from the pylon
but when you're near the pylon it
supercharges your your tactical so you
get fences faster so if you drop it down
it's uh it's a it's a permanent
structure until it's destroyed and that
allows you to build these large
fortresses very rapidly you can use that
for defending for flank control on
offensive squads for going up on a tower
and fencing it off with pathfinder and
then the passive is that ultimate
accelerants give you your ultimate 100%
ultimate charge and so if you save up
ultimate accelerants over the course of
the match that allows you to place more
pylons and it means that you don't have
to play conservatively as watson as long
as you save up ultimate charges you can
keep moving with this with a highly
mobile squad you can play offense
defense support however you feel like
the fences and the pylon are most
effective to whatever comp your plan
well you're telling me here is that
lifeline mains do not need to
continuously hold ultimate accelerants
anymore we that was that was we felt
like we needed to a choice that's right
we did it people finally cuz everyone's
like really mean to me if I don't like
use the old six that's not fair
oh wow so that is that is that is
ridiculous across the fences you get
pinged as well yeah so if any enemies
cross through the pense defenses it
pings your entire squad so there's a
situational awareness
element to them as well Wow if you know
this is why like she grew up in the
arena if you know where all the choke
points the edges of the exits are you
can set up fences there and you'll know
exactly what it doesn't yes I'm even
thinking about like compositions and how
like it could work out you know maybe
for any Gibralter mains out there maybe
you find a little no one cheered for
that feels bad man maybe there's like a
little little synergy there that King
King created there's a lot that can be
done with these fences and being able to
block off certain chokes yeah it's I
think it's really the big sort of the
ceiling is how creative people can get
with it and I'm really excited to see
what people do with it and and from the
from an art perspective here you know
they're very distinct they stand out
what were some of the challenges in
making sure that these fences really
like when a player saw him they knew
they knew exactly what it was not to
kind of catch him off guard so to speak
to make it really really stand out in
the arena yeah again silhouettes
everything you got to make it stand out
and it has to look like it lives in the
world that she's something it's
something that she can use and that
lives on her body as well she's able to
pull it out and she's able to bring it
out and you know create a creative
fortress basically and it has to read so
we had concept artists working on every
little detail and the modelers as well
and we had to test it out we tested out
we play it in game or in house and make
sure it reads well and these guys do a
tremendous job of it to him like I need
like a post with electricity like it was
between the two yeah and they just they
create really cool stuff with just that
kind of vague hand-wavy
yeah description about it it's clearly
been thought out this this this legend
is gonna be incredible I can't wait to
play watts you guys excited Watson that
is nutty all right well again very much
looking for right now today we've
covered a bunch here we've seen a new
weapon we've gotten a new mode the
latest legend and the new battle pass
for season two so let's recap all the
amazing apex legend